a heartbreaking story in Indonesia this
morning where the soccer World is
morning 125 fans who died in a stadium
Stampede in Indonesia now this happened
at the end of the game on Saturday after
some people just ran onto the field
officials say 32 of the Dead are
children a government Minister says
families of those who died will be
compensated as Elizabeth Palmer reports
Witnesses say the police response
actually led to This Disaster
the tragedy began when fans streamed
onto the field Furious that their team
arima had lost a home game Riot police
followed and escorted one player to
safety but soon it was Mayhem police hid
out with their batons while fans
attacked a police vehicle and clouds of
tear gas fill the air even though
International rules ban its use indoors
you can see a panicked crowd rushing for
the exit but not the lethal Crush that
followed just those who could still walk
helping those who couldn't to ambulances
fans Spectators and two police officers
died both inside the stadium and later
in the hospital
got out with a broken arm asked how the
Panic began he said it was the tear gas
relieved families found near injured in
hospital beds heartbroken families
waited outside the morgue while the
president of international soccer Gianni
Infantino sent condolences this is a
dark day for football
and the tragedy Beyond Comprehension
comprehension is what Indonesians seek
from police and soccer authorities who
are promising to investigate for CBS
mornings I'm Elizabeth Palmer in Tokyo